estos dos camiones que dividen la ciudad
de metrovica en dos ilustran el actual
aumento de la tensión entre kosovo y
Serbia una separación entre la parte sur
de mayoría albanesa y la parte norte de
mayoría Serbia se trata del más reciente
episodio del tira y afloja entre las dos
etnias que viene desde el 10 de
diciembre los serbios del norte de
kosovo multiplican sus acciones para
exigir la liberación de un antiguo
policía serbio acusado por Cristina de
haber agredido a las fuerzas del orden
durante las manifestaciones para el
gobierno kosovar esta detención no tiene
un beneficio para la comunidad por lo
que llama a los manifestantes a
desbloquear el tráfico
según una noticia falsa que sigue
apareciendo la policía de kosovo tiene
una lista de antiguos policías serbios
que van a ser detenidos no tenemos tan
lista y no existe
un llamado a la calma que no fue
escuchado por el lado serbio Belgrado
incluso puso a su ejército y policía en
alerta máxima una respuesta a la
negativa de kosovo el día anterior a
dejar en el país al patriarca de la
iglesia ortodoxa Serbia
su objetivo final es expulsar a los
serbios de kosovo en el futuro los
kosovares quieren expulsar a Serbia de
kosovo y metohisha pero si muchos
denuncian que se trata de una
provocación más en la frontera los
habitantes no parece muy preocupados
estamos acostumbrados a estas tensiones
no es nada nuevo para nosotros llevamos
20 años viviendo en este clima pero
intentamos llevar una vida normal
kosovo declaró su independencia en 2008
pero Serbia nunca ha accedido a
reconocer su soberanía pristina y
Belgrado siguen en conversaciones en
Bruselas para tratar de normalizar sus
relaciones